legal eagle is coming in loud and clear
thanks to ting in mobile over 70% of
Americans say that they want witnesses
and documents in the Senate impeachment
trial of Donald Trump that didn't
actually come out in the house
proceedings and 70% of Americans don't
agree on anything as of the recording of
this video john bolton logged his own
bombshell that his book allegedly states
that donald trump personally ordered the
quid pro quo of leveraging hundreds of
millions of dollars of ukrainian aid for
investigations or announcements of
investigations into the Biden's some
want john bolton and others to testify
it some want to prevent john bolton and
others from testifying it's time to
think like a lawyer
[Music]
hey legal eagles it's time to think like
a lawyer because in this debate a lot of
people are referring to historical
precedent as a reason to call witnesses
or not call witnesses at the Senate
impeachment trial but the thing about
making appeals to prior precedent in
this context is that there's not very
much of it when people say that these
impeachment proceedings are breaking
with precedent or are unprecedented what
they mean is that it's not like the only
two other instances that this happened
in the modern era because there's only
two instances that are related to
impeachment but even the impeachment
proceedings regarding Richard Nixon
didn't result in a formal impeachment in
the house or a Senate trial and
sometimes it's helpful to refer back to
the impeachment of Andrew Johnson in the
1830s but that is such an odd situation
that is almost soui generous and
references to it can be problematic I
did a prior video on this you can check
out my prior impeachment videos to learn
about the impeachment of Andrew Johnson
so given that impeachment is such a rare
event in American politics precedent can
be of limited value it's absolutely
instructional but it's by no means
dispositive now in this context the
argument that I hear from certain
corners of the internet is that it's the
House of Representatives that does the
investigation and the Senate simply
looks at the evidence that the house
gathered now that's not wrong strictly
speaking but it's also definitely not
entirely true either and I also hear
people on both sides of the aisle make
the
analogy to criminal law the House of
Representatives files an indictment ie
the charging instrument against a
criminal defendant and then the Senate
tries the case and we'll talk about
whether that fits in a second but first
let's look at what happened in Prior
impeachments to understand why this one
is different to the extent that it is
actually different now I mentioned this
in a prior video but one of the biggest
differences that stands out to me as
someone that actually studied the
Watergate and Clinton impeachment
extensively in college as a former
political scientist and someone who has
studied constitutional law and
separation of powers in law school one
of the things that really sticks out to
me is that in both cases there was an
extensive investigation by the executive
branch into the acts of Nixon and
Clinton and I think it's helpful to go
over some of the timelines for the Nixon
and Clinton impeachments to understand
just how wide-ranging these
investigations were so let's start with
a really quick timeline of what happened
to Richard Nixon as you may know the
Watergate break-in was in June of 1972
five people have been arrested and
charged with breaking into the
headquarters of the Democratic National
Committee in the middle of the night
then it was almost a year later that the
Senate not the house began hearings in
May of 1973 will inquire into every fact
and follow every lead unrestrained by
any fair look where that lead might
ultimately take us that was a year later
oh and by the way speaking of those
Senate Watergate hearings during those
hearings several of Nixon's cabinet
members aides and advisers actually gave
testimony including his Attorney General
his chief of staff his top domestic
adviser and White House Counsel they all
gave testimony before the Senate after
the Senate hearings into the Watergate
break-in Attorney General Elliot
Richardson appointed Archibald Cox
special prosecutor in May of 1973
so effectively Richard Nixon's own
attorney general appointed a special
prosecutor right after the Senate
started hearing and two months after
Archibald Cox was appointed special
prosecutor he subpoenaed the famous
Nixon tapes from the White House we will
initiate such legal measures
the eight tapes and certain other
evidence as soon as proper papers can be
prepared
of course famously the White House
refused to comply with the special
prosecutors subpoena and didn't turn the
tapes over at that point the special
prosecutor went to court and the case
went to the court of appeals which
didn't actually rule until October of
1973 and in a five to two decision the
Court of Appeals ordered the white house
to turn over the tapes but at that point
the white house resisted and refused to
turn the tapes over to the special
prosecutor this is in fall of 1973 the
Nixon White House did offer a compromise
which I think is one of the funnier
footnotes the whole Watergate affair
Nixon offered to turn the tapes over
which were famously low-quality
to senator Stennis who was famously
almost deaf and the compromise was that
senator Stennis would review these tapes
and then turn over any inculpatory
evidence to this festival prosecutor the
idea being that there was no way he
could actually hear what was being
discussed on the tapes but I digress
what's important here is that despite
the court of appeals ordering the White
House to comply Nixon refused to comply
with the Court of Appeals decision and
in fact ordered AG Richardson to fire
Archibald Cox the president at that
point thought he had no choice but to
direct the Attorney General to discharge
mr. Cox felt equally clear that I could
not discharge him and so I resign
attorney general Richardson refused to
actually fire Archibald Cox but as a
result the president fired AG Richardson
which resulted in the famous Saturday
night massacre which resulted in not
only AG Richardson resigning but also
Archibald Cox being fired as well by
Robert Bork shortly thereafter Archibald
Cox was replaced by special prosecutor
Leon Jaworski who continued the
investigation I was given unqualified
assurance that there would be absolutely
no constraints on my freedom to seek any
and all evidence now a formal
impeachment inquiry did not start until
February 1974 and it wasn't until July
of 1974 that the Supreme Court issued
the unanimous decision in United States
versus Nixon
to turn over the Nixon White House tapes
and finally it wasn't until August 1974
that the tapes were actually released
these are the famous smoking gun Nixon
tapes and in fact Nixon resigned in
August of 1974 shortly after these tapes
were released in part because the
executive wasn't willing to contradict
the Supreme Court at that point I shall
resign the presidency effective at noon
tomorrow and he resigned before he was
even formally impeached by the house or
tried by the Senate so in terms of
takeaways that we all should be able to
agree upon from the Nixon Watergate
impeachment affair I think there are a
couple things that we can glean number
one there was a massive executive branch
investigation before the house was even
involved in the house and the special
prosecutor didn't even get involved
before there were hearings at the Senate
this investigation by the special
prosecutor's office of the executive
branch took literally years it was also
obstructed by the White House and
required not just a Court of Appeals
decision but also a decision by the
United States Supreme Court and on top
of that the investigation by the special
prosecutor was started by attorney
general Elliot Richardson who is the
equivalent of Bill Bar today part of the
difference that we see today is that
Attorney General Bill Barr refused to
start any investigation into the
Ukrainian allegations that's the reason
it's alleged that the whistleblower came
forward and had to blow a whistle there
was no action by the executive branch
that's why the whistleblower is a
whistleblower the executive branch
including attorney general bill Bar
Counsel for the CIA and White House
Counsel did nothing about these eleska
conversation or the other actions that
are alleged another takeaway is that
this litigation involving the subpoena
of the White House tapes took years it
was incredibly time-consuming has
litigation tends to be as you may know
in the the federal courts what you're
talking about is a trial court which is
a district court and then the trial
court's decision is appealed to the
court of appeals and only then after the
court of appeals has weighed in on the
subject can something go to the Supreme
Court and here we've seen examples where
that litigation has
in an extremely long time right now
there are ongoing cases regarding the
litigation of Donald Trump's tax returns
and the litigation of the allegation
that the Trump Hotel is an improper
emolument and is a benefit to the
president and in fact with respect to
the emoluments litigation one of those
cases has already gone to the Court of
Appeal and was remanded back down to the
district court so it's sort of back
where it started so it's a long way from
getting to the Supreme Court and believe
it or not the litigation in the Nixon
case where the Supreme Court didn't
actually issue a formal decision until
late 1974 that's actually fast if
usually takes a lot longer than that for
a case to be adjudicated by the Supreme
Court so that's the impeachment of
Richard Nixon in a nutshell but let's
talk about the impeachment of Bill
Clinton
well that impeachment starts in 1994
even though it didn't resolve until 1999
in the Clinton proceedings Kenneth Starr
was appointed as independent counsel in
August of 1994 with the approval of
Attorney General Janet Reno in the wake
of the Nixon impeachment the special
prosecutor statutes were replaced with
the Independent Counsel statutes later
on so Kenneth Starr was appointed in
1994 to investigate what's called the
whitewater affair which are certain real
estate related allegations related to
when Clinton was in private practice and
although Kenneth Starr was appointed to
investigate the whitewater affair the
investigation broadened over time to
include a number of different things
including the death of Vince foster the
firing of certain White House travel
office personnel potential abuse of
confidential FBI files and eventually
the Paula Jones lawsuit and eventually
the possible perjury and obstruction of
justice to cover-up President Clinton's
sexual relationship with Monica Lewinsky
and to this day part of the controversy
over the Starr investigation is that it
started regarding the whitewater issue
but ballooned into including something
else entirely over the course of five to
six years and took on subsequent
controversies as they came up now
roughly at the same time in 1994 Paula
Jones filed suit and accused President
Clinton of sexual harassment when he was
governor
Arkansas Clinton attempted to delay the
trial the civil trial over the Paula
Jones lawsuit until after he left office
but in May of 1997 the Supreme Court
unanimously rejected Clinton's claim
that the Constitution immunized him from
civil lawsuits and shortly thereafter
pretrial discovery commenced in the
Paula Jones lawsuit as part of the Paula
Jones lawsuit in January of 1998 Clinton
gave a deposition in the Jones
litigation where he denied having a
sexual relationship with Monica Lewinsky
I've never had sexual relations with
Monica Lewinsky I never had an affair
with her a few months later in August of
1998 President Clinton testified in
front of a grand jury convened by the
Office of Independent Counsel ie
Kenneth Starr and actually testified for
four hours about his relationship with
Monica Lewinsky and whether he had
perjured himself before I knew that in
the face of their illegal activity I
still had to behave lawfully but I
wanted to be legal without being
particularly helpful you might have
heard of the famous testimony of
President Clinton where he says it
depends on what your definition of is is
well this is where it comes from from
the testimony in front of the grand jury
in 1998 a few months later in September
of 1998 Kenneth Starr and the office of
independent counsel concluded its four
year-long investigation of the president
soon after the president's grand jury
testimony and delivered the famous Starr
report to the House Judiciary Committee
the Starr report itself was extensive it
was 453 pages long
Republican House leaders argued for the
reports immediate release via the
internet which was new at the time while
the Democrats tried to delay to allow
the White House time to form a response
but after two days of debate on
September 11th 1998 the House voted in a
huge majority to release the report to
the public after which formal
impeachment of President Clinton started
in October of 1998 really just a month
after the Star report came out just a
few months later in December of 1998 the
House voted to impeach President
Clinton and in January of 1999 the
Senate began its trial of President
Clinton in February of 1999 the Senate
began taking closed-door depositions of
witnesses and in that same month the
Senate voted 70 to 30 that excerpting
the videotapes of these closed-door
depositions would suffice as testimony
rather than calling live witnesses to
appear at trial and then famously Bill
Clinton was acquitted in the Senate
two-thirds of the Senators present not
having pronounced him guilty the Senate
a judges that the respondent William
Jefferson Clinton President of the
United States is not guilty as charged
so what are the takeaways from the
Clinton impeachment proceedings well
once again we have a massive
investigation by the executive branch
this time from the office of Independent
Counsel that investigation took multiple
years basically five years from start to
finish and the house didn't really do
the investigation at all in fact it was
just a matter of days between the
release of the Starr report and
impeachment proceedings and eventually
actual formal impeachment by the house
on top of that the president testified
multiple times both in depositions in
civil court in the Paula Jones
litigation a deposition in the Senate
trial and in front of the grand jury
pursuant to the investigation of the
office of Independent Counsel and as
with the impeachment of Richard Nixon it
required a decision by the US Supreme
Court even though Paula Jones started
her litigation in 1994 it wasn't until
1997 that the Supreme Court said that
the president was not immune and that
the civil suit could go forward in the
president could be deposed and if we
were specifically talking about
witnesses in the trial before the Senate
well there's not a lot of history here
when it comes to impeachment trials and
presidents it's only happened twice with
Andrew Johnson in 1868 and Bill Clinton
in 1999 in the impeachment case of
Andrew Johnson in 1868 there were
actually 41 witnesses called and in the
case of Bill Clinton there were three
including Monica Lewinsky herself so
with that historical context let's talk
about the analogy that the house in
Deitz because impeachment is like an
indictment and the idea that the Senate
tries because they have the power to try
the impeachment so in the American
criminal law contact
you can start criminal prosecution with
some but not all of the evidence that
you want indictment is a very low
standard and you can get more evidence
at and during trial in a civil case you
get what's called discovery which is
meant to prevent you from being ambushed
at trial but even there you can get new
evidence at trial if it wasn't available
earlier on and in the criminal law
context you often hear from witnesses
for the very first time at trial because
you don't get discovery in a criminal
case often and it can also be true that
the evidence is overwhelming at the
indictment stage but it could also be
true that you want more evidence at the
time of trial
it can also be true that you have some
evidence at the start or at the
indictment phase but that you need more
evidence to meet the hurdle that is
required for conviction the standard for
indictment is incredibly low it's
probable cause probable cause that some
conduct that gives rise to the crime or
the offense is elicited but the standard
for conviction is beyond a reasonable
doubt which is much much higher and
criminal investigations are always
ongoing so you might have to file an
indictment to say beat a statute of
limitations problem and then you go
forward with trial as new things come
about and in fact in many states
prosecutors can actually withhold
evidence from defendants until trial
so every defendant gets new information
and new evidence when the trial starts
but again these are just analogies these
aren't required by the Constitution the
Constitution requires neither probable
cause nor guilt beyond a reasonable
doubt at the impeachment or conviction
stage the House and Senate can use
whatever standards they want which is
why impeachment is often called a
political tool sometimes the analogies
break down the house isn't a police
force or an office of District
Attorney's they have some tools but
generally speaking criminal defendants
don't get to claim executive privilege
or block witnesses from testifying at
the criminal investigation or trial of
that defendant and generally criminal
defendants don't get to control the
investigation of the police or decide if
there even is an investigation in the
first place so
these impeachment proceedings different
from the other two modern impeachment
proceedings well yes they couldn't not
be but that begs the question that it's
different in an improper way here a lot
stems from attorney general bars in
action you could say that the house
didn't do the same kind of thorough
investigation that the house did in the
Nixon and Clinton affairs or that they
rushed the investigation but the house
has never had to carry the investigatory
laboring or before in the last two
modern impeachments there was always a
massive executive branch investigation
and although we don't know everything
about John Bolton's testimony in part
because he hasn't given it yet it's
possible that attorney general Barr is
conflicted out by all accounts he may
have buried concerns about the zalenski
called rudy giuliani's actions and the
whistleblower again we don't know the
details here but that's also kind of the
point one wonders what history would
look like if Attorney General Richardson
had stonewalled and never appointed
Archibald Cox or if Janet Reno had
quashed ken starr's appointment as the
Independent Counsel and never
investigated the Whitewater
investigation any of the Trump related
legal questions would not have been
resolved by the US Supreme Court until
almost certainly after the 20/20
election
this gives talking points to both sides
some will claim that it was the houses
duty to engage in that litigation and
some will say that it was futile there's
certainly no constitutional requirement
for the house to go forward but again
that tactic gives talking points to both
sides all things being equal I would
certainly love for the Supreme Court to
weigh in on these questions in part
because I think it's clear how the
Supreme Court would weigh in given the
precedent of US vs. Nixon in 1973
Clinton versus Jones and us versus Nixon
in 1993 which is a different Nixon but I
suppose that what you think the role of
the House the Senate and the Supreme
Court is in this context is a political
question and reasonable Minds can differ
about that but at base there's nothing
constitutionally infirm a bow
it's the length of time or the amount of
investigation that the house did it's
not required by the Constitution to call
every witness that might have relevant
testimony and hear history and precedent
certainly diverge it's not wrong to say
that in the past the house has
investigated the evidence about
impeachable conduct but it's also not
entirely right either in the past the
house has had the benefit of a huge
executive branch investigation
ironically for Nixon and Clinton it
would probably be most accurate to say
that it wasn't the house that
investigated so much as the executive
branch that investigated itself with
assists from the United States Supreme
Court which the house then relied on it
is however wrong to say that witnesses
are improper at the Senate trial it
happened with the Senate impeachment
trial of President Clinton and it
happened with the Senate impeachment
trial of President Johnson though for
reasons I've talked about in other
videos the impeachment of Andrew Johnson
is kind of a weird animal so to argue
that these proceedings comport with past
precedent or diverge from past precedent
is more like the start of the
conversation rather than the end we've
only had two Senate trials in all of
American history and in those particular
cases there there were witnesses and of
course it's also factually incorrect to
say that the house had no evidence and
no witnesses when it voted to impeach
President Trump they had lots of
evidence but whether you think that was
enough evidence to vote for impeachment
and even the standard that the house of
representatives should use to decide if
there is enough evidence is probably
another political question that I live
to you but whether the house rush to the
impeachment hearing and the impeachment
decision is probably inchoate to the
question of whether there should be
additional evidence and witnesses at the
Senate trial again going back to the
analogy of a criminal indictment so long
as the house had enough to suspect
presidential wrongdoing then it's enough
to send it to the Senate and if the
Senate wants more evidence and witnesses
or if it needs more evidence and
witnesses it doesn't mean that the house
investigation was infirm or that the
was weak it just might mean that there's
other relevant evidence out there and
that the Senate wants to see it but the
bottom line is that the Senate will soon
vote on additional witnesses documents
and subpoenas in the Senate trial and
it's more important than ever to call
your senator and tell them that you are
part of the 75% of Americans who want
witnesses and maybe even the testimony
of President Trump as in the Clinton
proceedings the phone numbers of the
most important Senators are in the
description and if you're going to make
that call and yell at your senator you
might as well save a ton of money with
ting Mobile t-mobile is a different kind
of mobile provider with ting you only
pay for the actual data and services you
use at the end of the month and because
you're only paying for what you actually
use ting customers pay on average just
23 dollars per month for one of their
mobile devices there is no contract
overage fees or any other carrier tricks
you just pay a fair price for the talk
text and data that you use up every
month and ting has award-winning
customer service because they don't have
any brick-and-mortar stores they pour
their resources into their phone support
if you have an issue give them a call
and you'll immediately talk to a real
human being and if you're like me and
you would rather avoid talking to any
actual real human beings they offer
support through chat email social media
and even discord with ting you can use
almost any cell phone including the
newest iPhones and pixel phones and you
can use the same phone number that
you're using right now ting provides
excellent LTE coverage because it uses
both the t-mobile and Sprint networks so
even if the FTC blocks the merger of
Sprint and t-mobile you can still get
the best of both worlds and what saying
especially if you're around Wi-Fi all
the time which most of us are you'll end
up paying way less than you do now sure
it might make sense for some people to
pay $200 per month for unlimited data
but if you're surrounded by Wi-Fi all
day long you might be paying hundreds of
dollars more per month completely
unnecessarily ting gives you the option
to pay for only what you use so if you
go to legal Eagle ting comm you can use
your last bill to compare just how much
you would save if you switch to ting if
you save anything at all and legal
eagles will get a twenty five dollar
credit just by going to legal eagle
Tinkham or clicking the link in the
description and that could cover
literally the entire first month of your
cell phone bill with ting and since
there are no contracts you can try it
for a month no string
attached again all you have to do is
click on the link in the description or
go to legal eagle ting comm get a twenty
five dollar credit for whatever service
you want plus clicking on the link
really helps out this channel so do you
agree with my analysis do you think that
there should be witnesses in the Senate
trial or do you think that the house
really screwed the pooch in their
investigation leave your objections in
the comments and check out this playlist
of all of my other real law reactions
where I talk about impeachment related
things copyright all of the legal news
that's in the news and is fit to print
just click on the playlist